selamat datang kembali di Understanding Quantum Information and Computation, nama saya John Watrous dan saya adalah direktur teknis untuk pendidikan di IBM
Quantum. Ini adalah pelajaran ke-14 dari seri ini dan merupakan pelajaran kedua dari unit keempat yang membahas tentang error
koreksi Quantum. Pada pelajaran sebelumnya, kita sudah melihat sekilas tentang koreksi error Quantum termasuk nine qubit Shore code yang membuktikan bahwa
koreksi error Quantum itu memungkinkan secara teori. Kita juga membahas diskretisasi error yang memungkinkan kita
untuk mengoreksi error Quantum yang sembarang pada qubit dengan cara memproyeksikannya ke bit flip dan phase
flip. Pada pelajaran ini, kita akan membahas formalisme stabilizer yang merupakan alat matematika yang bisa kita gunakan
untuk mendefinisikan dan menganalisis kelas luas dari kode koreksi error Quantum yang dikenal sebagai kode stabilizer. Ini mencakup 9 qubit Shore
code beserta banyak contoh lainnya termasuk kode-kode yang kemungkinan jauh lebih cocok untuk perangkat Quantum di dunia nyata
dibandingkan Shore code. Tidak semua kode koreksi error Quantum adalah kode stabilizer, tapi banyak yang termasuk
termasuk setiap contoh yang akan kita lihat di seri ini. Tentu ada kode koreksi error Quantum yang menarik dan berpotensi berguna
yang bukan kode stabilizer, tapi kode-kode itu cenderung lebih rumit dan bagaimanapun juga tidak ada
keraguan bahwa formalisme stabilizer adalah landasan utama dalam fondasi koreksi error Quantum dan kita akan
banyak mengandalkannya untuk sisa unit ini. Berikut gambaran singkat pelajaran ini: kita akan mulai dengan diskusi singkat
tentang matriks Pauli dan perkalian tensor dari matriks Pauli yang bisa merepresentasikan operasi pada qubit maupun
pengukuran qubit. Seperti yang akan saya jelaskan, dalam konteks ini kita sering menyebutnya sebagai observable. Kita kemudian akan kembali dan
melihat repetition code dari sudut pandang kedua dan kita akan lihat bagaimana mendeskripsikannya melalui operasi dan observable Pauli, yang akan
menginformasikan dan mengarah ke diskusi umum tentang kode stabilizer termasuk beberapa contoh, sifat dasar kode stabilizer,
dan bagaimana kita melakukan tugas-tugas fundamental yaitu encoding, mendeteksi error, dan mengoreksi
error tersebut. Kita akan mulai pelajaran ini dengan diskusi singkat tentang operasi Pauli, terutama untuk mempersiapkan
formalisme stabilizer, tapi juga untuk mengamati beberapa fakta kunci dan menetapkan terminologi dasar. Pertama, berikut adalah matriks Pauli
termasuk matriks identitas 2x2 beserta tiga matriks Pauli non-identitas yang akan kita notasikan dengan
huruf kapital X, Y, dan Z sepanjang sisa seri ini. Keempat matriks ini bersifat unitary dan Hermitian, dan kita bisa
mengidentifikasinya dengan operasi pada sebuah qubit termasuk operasi yang mungkin ingin kita lakukan maupun error, seperti yang
kita bahas di pelajaran sebelumnya. Matriks Pauli non-identitas X, Y, dan Z saling anti-commute satu sama lain,
artinya XY sama dengan -1 kali YX, XZ sama dengan negatif ZX, dan YZ sama dengan
negatif ZY. Dan kamu bisa dengan mudah memverifikasi hubungan-hubungan ini dengan melakukan perkaliannya. Hubungan anti-komutasi ini
sangat sederhana tapi sangat penting dalam formalisme stabilizer dan di tempat lain. Secara khusus,
seperti yang akan kita lihat, tanda minus yang muncul saat kita menukar urutan dua matriks Pauli non-identitas yang berbeda dalam perkalian berkorespondensi tepat dengan
deteksi error dalam formalisme stabilizer. Kita juga punya aturan perkalian yang tercantum di sini. Setiap
matriks Pauli adalah inversnya sendiri yang konsisten dengan fakta bahwa keduanya unitary dan Hermitian, dan jika kamu mengalikan dua matriks Pauli non-identitas yang berbeda
kamu akan selalu mendapatkan plus atau minus I dikali matriks Pauli non-identitas yang tersisa.
Khususnya, hingga fase global Y ekuivalen dengan X dikali Z, yang menjelaskan fokus kita pada error X dan Z dalam
koreksi error Quantum. X merepresentasikan bit flip, Z merepresentasikan phase flip, dan hingga fase global Y merepresentasikan
kedua error tersebut yang terjadi pada qubit yang sama. Keempat matriks ini semua merepresentasikan
operasi atau error atau ketiadaan error pada satu qubit, tapi sering kali lebih mudah untuk men-tensor-kannya bersama
untuk melakukan operasi atau error pada beberapa qubit. Sebagai poin terminologi, kapan pun kita menyebut operasi Pauli N qubit,
yang kita maksud adalah perkalian tensor dari N matriks Pauli sembarang, seperti contoh-contoh yang ditunjukkan
di sini. Istilah operasi Pauli juga umum digunakan ketika ada fase global, tapi untuk menjaga segalanya sesederhana mungkin,
saya akan menggunakan istilah operasi Pauli untuk berarti sekadar perkalian tensor dari matriks-matriks Pauli. Bobot dari operasi Pauli N qubit
sederhananya adalah jumlah matriks Pauli non-identitas dalam perkalian tensor tersebut. Misalnya, perkalian tensor N-fold
dari matriks identitas 2x2 dengan dirinya sendiri adalah operasi Pauli berbobot nol. Perkalian tensor dari dua matriks Pauli X
dan sekelompok matriks identitas punya bobot dua, dan seterusnya. Secara intuitif, bobot dari operasi Pauli N
qubit adalah jumlah qubit di mana ia bekerja secara non-trivial. Dan lazimnya kode koreksi error Quantum dirancang
sehingga bisa mendeteksi dan mengoreksi error yang direpresentasikan oleh operasi Pauli hingga bobot tertentu. Kita bisa
memikirkan operasi Pauli dengan berbagai cara termasuk sebagai operasi yang sengaja dilakukan oleh Quantum Gate maupun
sebagai error. Dan kita juga akan segera lihat bahwa operasi Pauli bisa mendeskripsikan pengukuran. Kadang-kadang juga berguna
untuk memikirkan operasi Pauli sebagai generator dari himpunan-himpunan tertentu dalam pengertian aljabar yang mungkin kamu kenali
jika kamu familiar dengan teori grup. Kalau kamu tidak familiar dengan teori grup, tidak apa-apa, ini memang tidak begitu penting
untuk pelajaran ini, tapi kalau kamu tertarik mempelajari koreksi error Quantum lebih dalam, kamu mungkin akan merasa bahwa beberapa
dasar teori grup sangat membantu. Bagaimanapun, anggap saja P1 sampai PR adalah operasi Pauli N qubit
jadi P1 adalah operasi Pauli N qubit, P2 adalah operasi Pauli N qubit, dan seterusnya. Ketika kita menyebut himpunan yang dibangkitkan oleh
P1 sampai PR, yang kita maksud adalah himpunan semua matriks yang bisa kita peroleh dengan mengalikan matriks-matriks ini bersama dalam
kombinasi dan urutan manapun yang kita pilih, mengambil masing-masing sebanyak yang kita inginkan. Kita akan lihat beberapa contoh sebentar lagi
tapi pertama izinkan saya menyebutkan notasi yang kita gunakan untuk menunjukkan himpunan ini. Himpunan yang dibangkitkan oleh P1 sampai PR adalah
P1 sampai PR yang dipisahkan oleh koma di dalam tanda kurung sudut. Memang terlihat seperti kita bisa dengan mudah mengacaukan
notasi ini dengan notasi bra-ket, tapi itu umumnya tidak terjadi dan ini adalah notasi tradisional dalam teori
grup. Berikut contoh himpunan yang dibangkitkan oleh X, Y, dan Z, jadi N sama dengan satu dalam contoh ini karena tidak ada
perkalian tensor dan kita mengambil ketiga matriks Pauli non-identitas sebagai generator. Ternyata ada
16 matriks yang bisa dibangkitkan dengan membentuk perkalian yang mencakup ketiga matriks ini, dan kamu bisa menelusuri ini
melalui aturan perkalian yang kita lihat tadi. Secara khusus, kita tentu bisa mendapatkan X, Y, dan Z beserta identitas
dan sebenarnya kita juga bisa mendapatkan keempat matriks ini dikali I, 1, atau negatif I. Dan itulah
WEBVTT
semuanya. Himpunan ini umumnya dikenal sebagai grup Pauli. Kita juga bisa mempertimbangkan himpunan yang
dibangkitkan hanya oleh X dan Z, dan kita akan mendapatkan setengah dari grup Pauli dalam kasus ini.
Dan satu contoh terakhir setidaknya untuk sekarang, kita bisa mempertimbangkan himpunan yang dibangkitkan oleh X tensor X dan Z tensor Z, jadi N sama dengan
dua dalam kasus ini, dan kita hanya mendapatkan empat elemen kali ini karena X tensor X dan Z tensor Z
commute satu sama lain. Matriks Pauli dan operasi Pauli N qubit secara lebih umum mendeskripsikan
operasi unitary apakah itu error atau sengaja dilakukan, tapi mereka juga mendeskripsikan
pengukuran. Lebih tepatnya, mulai dari tiga matriks Pauli non-identitas, kita bisa mengasosiasikan masing-masing
matriks dengan pengukuran projektif yang didefinisikan dalam hal nilai eigen dan vektor eigennya. Dan di sini di layar kita
punya dekomposisi spektral dari matriks-matriks ini yang akan membantu mengklarifikasi hal ini. Intinya, ketika kita menyebut pengukuran X,
pengukuran Y, atau pengukuran Z, yang kita maksud adalah pengukuran projektif yang didefinisikan oleh proyeksi
ke ruang eigen dari matriks-matriks ini. Dan biasanya kita menganggap nilai eigen sebagai hasil pengukuran yang bersesuaian.
Misalnya, pengukuran X adalah pengukuran terhadap basis plus minus dari sebuah qubit,
atau alternatifnya kita bisa mendeskripsikannya dengan himpunan yang berisi proyeksi ket plus bra plus dan ket
minus bra minus. Pengukuran Z di sisi lain tidak lain hanyalah pengukuran basis standar.
Meskipun seperti yang tadi saya katakan, kadang-kadang kita mengidentifikasi nilai eigen dengan hasil pengukuran, dan jika kita lakukan
itu maka hasilnya adalah plus satu dan minus satu, bukan 0 dan 1. Sebenarnya kita bisa melakukan sesuatu
yang serupa untuk matriks Hermitian sembarang, dan istilah observable umum digunakan dalam situasi ini. Untuk matriks Pauli
dan operasi Pauli N qubit secara lebih umum, kita bisa melakukan pengukuran seperti itu secara non-destruktif menggunakan
estimasi fase. Dan hanya untuk memastikan diagram ini jelas, di sini kita melakukan pengukuran secara non-destruktif pada
qubit teratas, sedangkan qubit bawah selalu diinisialisasi ke keadaan plus, atau dengan kata lain Hadamard diterapkan ke keadaan
nol, karena itulah cara estimasi fase bekerja. Perhatikan bahwa karena nilai eigen
hanya plus satu dan minus satu dalam kasus ini, kita hanya butuh satu qubit kontrol yang merupakan qubit bawah dalam
diagram ini. Lebih dari itu hanya akan membuang-buang sumber daya karena hanya ada satu bit presisi yang perlu dikhawatirkan. Nilai eigen
entah plus satu atau minus satu, dan pengukurannya sudah sempurna seperti ini. Hasil dari pengukuran ini omong-omong,
yaitu pengukuran basis standar dalam circuit, akan menjadi nol untuk hasil nilai eigen plus satu
yang bersesuaian dengan keadaan plus dalam kasus observable X, dan hasilnya adalah satu untuk nilai eigen minus satu
atau keadaan minus dalam kasus ini. Semua yang baru saja saya katakan secara alami berlaku untuk operasi Pauli N qubit,
asalkan kita ingat bahwa ketika kita berbicara tentang observable, kita sedang membicarakan tentang mengukur nilai eigen,
bukan mengukur terhadap basis vektor eigen. Misalnya, pertimbangkan operasi Pauli dua
qubit Z tensor Z. Sekali lagi ada dua nilai eigen plus satu dan minus satu, jadi
pengukurannya dijelaskan oleh dua proyeksi. Perhatikan khususnya bahwa pengukuran yang kita asosiasikan dengan
observable ini tidak sama dengan mengukur kedua qubit dengan pengukuran Z, atau dengan kata lain pengukuran basis standar, melainkan itu adalah pengukuran projektif dua
hasil di mana proyeksinya ke ruang yang dibentuk oleh semua vektor eigen yang bersesuaian dengan
masing-masing dari dua nilai eigen plus satu dan minus satu. Cara lain untuk memikirkan ini adalah bahwa nilai eigen dari perkalian tensor
adalah perkalian dari nilai eigen masing-masing matriks yang kita jadikan perkalian tensornya. Dan
karena negatif 1 dikali negatif 1 sama dengan positif 1 dikali positif 1 misalnya, pengukuran ini tidak
membedakan antara 00 dan 11. Jadi jika kita mengukur misalnya keadaan Bell phi plus dengan pengukuran
yang dijelaskan oleh observable ini, kita pasti akan mendapatkan hasil yang bersesuaian dengan nilai eigen plus satu
dan keadaan tidak berubah, berbeda dengan runtuh ke 00 atau 11 yang akan terjadi jika kita
melakukan pengukuran basis standar pada dua qubit tersebut. Jadi pengukuran Z tensor Z tidak
sama dengan melakukan dua pengukuran Z secara independen, tapi sebenarnya kita bisa melakukan pengukuran seperti ini menggunakan estimasi
fase dengan cara yang persis sama seperti sebelumnya menggunakan satu qubit kontrol, seperti yang ditunjukkan dalam diagram circuit yang
berlaku untuk operasi Pauli N qubit manapun sebagai pengganti Z tensor Z. Ketika kita hanya punya matriks Pauli Z,
omong-omong, kita bisa menyederhanakan circuit seperti ini, dan apa yang ini ungkapkan yang juga terlihat dari proyeksi yang mendefinisikan
pengukuran adalah bahwa melakukan pengukuran Z tensor Z pada dua qubit ekuivalen dengan mengukur paritas mereka
dalam hal basis standar. Dan ini berlaku umum untuk perkalian tensor dari matriks Pauli Z dalam jumlah berapa pun.
Selanjutnya, kita akan melihat kembali repetition code tiga bit, kali ini diungkapkan dalam hal operasi Pauli.
Ini akan menjadi contoh pertama kita yang cukup sederhana tentang kode stabilizer, dan kita akan mendiskusikan cara menggeneralisasi konsep ini
sebentar lagi, tapi sangat membantu untuk melihat cara kerjanya dalam kasus sederhana ini terlebih dahulu. Ingat bahwa ketika kita menerapkan
repetition code 3-bit pada qubit, kita meng-encode keadaan qubit tertentu Alpha 0 plus beta 1 sebagai Alpha 000 plus beta 111
dan kita akan memberi encoding tiga qubit ini nama Psi untuk kenyamanan. Jadi berdasarkan definisi, Psi adalah encoding tiga qubit yang valid
dari keadaan qubit, tapi jika kita ingin memverifikasinya, cukup memeriksa bahwa dua persamaan berikut bernilai benar. Persamaan
pertama menyatakan bahwa menerapkan operasi Z pada dua qubit paling kiri dari Psi tidak melakukan apa-apa pada Psi, yang artinya bahwa
Psi adalah vektor eigen dari Z tensor Z tensor Identitas, atau ZZ identitas disingkat, dengan nilai eigen satu. Dan persamaan kedua
serupa kecuali operasi Z diterapkan pada dua qubit paling kanan. Idenya adalah jika kita memikirkan Psi
sebagai kombinasi linear dari keadaan basis standar, maka persamaan pertama mengimplikasikan bahwa kita hanya bisa memiliki koefisien non-nol untuk keadaan basis standar
di mana dua bit paling kiri punya paritas genap atau dengan kata lain sama, dan persamaan kedua mengimplikasikan bahwa kita hanya bisa
memiliki koefisien non-nol untuk keadaan basis standar yang dua bit paling kanannya punya paritas genap. Cara lain untuk memikirkan ini
adalah melihat dua operasi Pauli ini sebagai observable, dan jika kita mengukur dua observable ini menggunakan
circuit yang disederhanakan yang saya sebut tadi, maka kita pasti akan mendapatkan hasil pengukuran yang bersesuaian dengan nilai eigen plus satu
karena Psi adalah vektor eigen dari kedua observable dengan nilai eigen satu. Tapi versi sederhana gabungan dari
WEBVTT
circuit untuk mengukur observable secara independen tidak lain adalah circuit pemeriksaan paritas kita untuk repetition code 3-bit
dan jadi kita lihat bahwa dua persamaan kita bersama-sama ekuivalen dengan circuit pemeriksaan paritas yang menghasilkan 0 0
yang merupakan syndrome yang menunjukkan bahwa tidak ada error yang terdeteksi. Tiga operasi Pauli qubit
ZZ identitas dan identitas ZZ disebut generator stabilizer untuk kode ini dan stabilizer dari kode adalah himpunan
yang dibangkitkan oleh generator stabilizer. Himpunan ini, yaitu stabilizer, adalah objek matematika yang sangat penting
yang terkait dengan kode ini dan kita akan mendiskusikan lebih lanjut peran yang dimainkannya seiring pelajaran berlanjut. Untuk sekarang,
saya hanya akan menunjukkan bahwa kita bisa membuat pilihan yang berbeda untuk generator. Misalnya, kita bisa memilih Z identitas Z sebagai pengganti salah satu
dari generator yang kita pilih dan kode serta stabilizernya akan persis sama. Selanjutnya kita akan mempertimbangkan deteksi bit flip
untuk repetition code tiga bit dengan fokus pada interaksi dan hubungan di antara operasi Pauli
yang terlibat, yaitu generator stabilizer dan error itu sendiri. Misalkan kita sudah meng-encode sebuah
qubit menggunakan repetition code tiga bit dan error bit flip terjadi pada qubit paling kiri. Ini menyebabkan keadaan Psi kita
bertransformasi sesuai dengan aksi operasi X atau error X pada qubit paling kiri. Seperti yang sudah kita tahu, kita bisa mendeteksi
error ini dengan melakukan pemeriksaan paritas untuk repetition code tiga bit, atau ekuivalennya kita bisa mengukur
encoding secara non-destruktif dengan memperlakukan generator stabilizer sebagai observable. Mari mulai dengan generator stabilizer
pertama dan lihat apa yang terjadi. Keadaan kita telah terpengaruh oleh error X dan kita ingin memahami
bagaimana pengukuran generator stabilizer sebagai observable dipengaruhi oleh error ini. X dan Z anti-commute sedangkan
semua hal commute dengan matriks identitas, sehingga ZZ identitas anti-commute dengan X identitas
identitas. Jadi kita mendapat tanda minus saat urutannya dibalik, dan kita juga tahu bahwa ZZ identitas tidak melakukan apa-apa pada Psi
karena Psi adalah encoding yang valid dari sebuah qubit dan encoding yang valid selalu merupakan vektor eigen plus satu dari kedua generator
stabilizer. Itu membuat kita dengan negatif X identitas identitas yang diterapkan pada Psi, dan karenanya X identitas identitas yang diterapkan pada
Psi adalah vektor eigen dari ZZ identitas dengan nilai eigen negatif satu. Kita juga bisa melakukan sesuatu yang serupa
dengan generator stabilizer kedua, tapi kali ini error commute dengan generator stabilizer sehingga keadaan
yang rusak kembali merupakan vektor eigen dari generator stabilizer tapi kali ini nilai eigennya positif
satu. Jadi keadaan yang rusak adalah vektor eigen dari kedua generator stabilizer dan apakah nilai eigennya plus satu atau
minus satu ditentukan oleh apakah error commute atau anti-commute dengan masing-masing generator stabilizer. Untuk yang pertama,
error dan generator stabilizer anti-commute dan untuk yang kedua mereka commute, dan itu selalu akan menjadi salah satu atau yang lain karena dua
operasi Pauli manapun entah commute atau anti-commute. Sementara itu, keadaan aktual Psi sebenarnya tidak terlalu berperan penting
di sini kecuali bahwa generator stabilizer bekerja secara trivial pada keadaan ini. Jadi ketika kita memikirkan
deteksi error, kita benar-benar tidak perlu memikirkan keadaan yang di-encode secara spesifik. Yang penting hanyalah apakah error commute atau anti-
commute dengan masing-masing generator stabilizer. Jadi mari kita buat tabel yang punya satu baris untuk setiap generator stabilizer
dan satu kolom untuk setiap error. Di sini saya hanya menyertakan error yang bersesuaian dengan satu bit flip saja
beserta tidak ada error sama sekali yang ditunjukkan dengan identitas yang di-tensor dengan dirinya sendiri tiga kali. Kita bisa menambahkan lebih banyak kolom untuk error lain jika mau
tapi untuk sekarang kita akan fokus hanya pada error-error ini. Entri dalam tabel adalah plus satu atau minus satu bergantung pada
apakah error dan generator stabilizer commute atau anti-commute. Jadi untuk setiap error dalam tabel, kita bisa melihat
kolom yang bersesuaian untuk melihat bagaimana error tersebut akan mengubah encoding apapun menjadi vektor eigen plus satu atau minus satu
dari masing-masing generator stabilizer. Kolom-kolom ini bersesuaian tepat dengan syndrome yang akan kita dapatkan dari
pemeriksaan paritas yang ekuivalen dengan pengukuran non-destruktif dari generator stabilizer sebagai
observable. Tentu saja, entri dalam tabel ini adalah plus satu dan minus satu bukan nol dan satu. Dan
jika kamu suka, kamu bisa memikirkan syndrome sebagai string biner yang bersesuaian daripada kolom-kolom dari plus satu dan minus satu, tapi ada
korespondensi langsung, dan hanya untuk membuat koneksi antara syndrome dan nilai eigen lebih jelas dan langsung,
saya akan menyebut vektor-vektor dari plus satu dan minus satu ini sebagai syndrome seperti sebelumnya. Syndrome memberi tahu
kita sesuatu tentang error yang terjadi, dan khususnya jika kita tahu bahwa salah satu dari empat kemungkinan error ini
terjadi, syndrome menunjukkan kepada kita error mana itu, dan kita bisa mengoreksinya dengan menerapkan error tersebut lagi jika kita
mau. Selanjutnya saya hanya akan sedikit membahas tentang syndrome dan khususnya kita akan melihat lebih dekat pada
aspek aljabarnya. Encoding kita adalah keadaan tiga qubit sehingga mereka adalah vektor satuan dalam ruang vektor kompleks
berdimensi delapan, dan apa yang dilakukan empat kemungkinan syndrome adalah membagi ruang berdimensi delapan ini
menjadi empat subruang berdimensi dua, artinya vektor-vektor dalam salah satu dari subruang ini akan selalu memberi kita syndrome yang sama.
Lebih detailnya, diagram ini menggambarkan bagaimana ruang berdimensi delapan dibagi.
Setiap generator stabilizer membagi ruang menjadi dua subruang berdimensi sama yaitu ruang dari vektor eigen plus satu
dan ruang dari vektor eigen minus satu. Misalnya, vektor plus satu dari ZZ identitas adalah kombinasi linear
dari keadaan basis standar yang dua bit paling kirinya punya paritas genap, dan vektor eigen minus satu adalah kombinasi linear
dari keadaan basis standar yang dua bit paling kirinya punya paritas ganjil. Dan situasinya serupa untuk
generator stabilizer lainnya kecuali bahwa itu adalah dua bit paling kanan bukan dua bit paling kiri. Jadi keempat subruang ini mudah untuk
dideskripsikan dalam kasus ini karena ini adalah kode yang sangat sederhana. Khususnya, subruang
yang bersesuaian dengan syndrome plus satu plus satu adalah ruang yang dibentuk oleh ket 000 dan ket 111 yang merupakan ruang encoding yang valid,
dan itu disebut code space. Secara umum, ruang-ruang dibentuk oleh keadaan basis standar
yang ditunjukkan di kotak-kotak yang bersesuaian meskipun tidak selalu sejelas atau semudah itu untuk dilihat. Syndrome-syndrome tersebut
juga mempartisi semua operasi Pauli tiga qubit yang merepresentasikan kemungkinan error Pauli yang bisa terjadi menjadi empat koleksi berukuran sama
bergantung pada syndrome mana yang akan ditimbulkan oleh error itu. Misalnya, operasi Pauli manapun
yang commute dengan kedua generator stabilizer menghasilkan syndrome plus 1 plus 1. Dan di antara 64 kemungkinan operasi Pauli tiga
qubit, ada tepat 16 di antaranya dalam kategori ini termasuk tiga yang disebutkan di layar, dan demikian pula untuk tiga syndrome lainnya.
WEBVTT
Itu tidak jelas tapi memang benar dan sifat dasar ini bahwa syndrome mempartisi ruang keadaan
tempat encoding hidup dan semua kemungkinan error Pauli dalam ruang tersebut menjadi potongan-potongan berukuran sama adalah sesuatu yang
berlaku secara umum untuk kode stabilizer yang akan segera kita definisikan secara tepat. Meskipun ini kebanyakan hanyalah catatan tambahan,
ada baiknya menyebutkan bahwa operasi Pauli yang commute dengan kedua generator stabilizer, atau ekuivalennya
operasi Pauli yang menghasilkan syndrome plus 1 plus 1 tapi tidak sendiri proporsional dengan elemen stabilizer, ternyata berperilaku seperti
operasi Pauli satu qubit pada qubit Logical yang kita encode. Misalnya, XXX commute dengan
kedua generator stabilizer tapi tidak proporsional dengan elemen manapun dari stabilizer, dan memang jelas jika kamu
memikirkan kode ini sebentar bahwa efek yang ditimbulkan operasi ini pada encoding ekuivalen dengan gate X pada
qubit Logical yang di-encode. Dan sekali lagi ini adalah sesuatu yang berlaku umum untuk semua kode stabilizer. Sekarang saatnya untuk mendefinisikan kode stabilizer
secara umum, dan cara kerjanya adalah kita melakukan sesuatu yang benar-benar analogis dengan apa yang baru saja kita diskusikan untuk
repetition code tiga bit, kecuali bahwa kita memilih generator stabilizer yang berbeda yang saya sebut semua sebagai P1
sampai PR untuk keperluan penjelasan ini. Generator stabilizer ini semuanya harus berupa operasi Pauli N qubit
di mana N adalah jumlah qubit yang digunakan untuk encoding, dan kita tidak bisa asal memilih himpunan generator stabilizer. Mereka
harus memenuhi beberapa kondisi dasar. Pertama, generator stabilizer semuanya harus commute satu sama
lain. Dalam kasus repetition code tiga bit, kita tidak repot-repot memperhatikan ini tapi memang mudah diamati bahwa ZZ identitas dan identitas
ZZ memang commute karena Z commute dengan dirinya sendiri dan semua hal commute dengan
identitas. Untuk kode stabilizer dengan generator stabilizer yang lebih rumit, di sisi lain, termasuk kode di mana kita punya
X dan Z yang muncul dalam generator stabilizer, ini adalah kondisi penting yang perlu
diperiksa. Satu cara untuk memikirkan kebutuhan akan kondisi ini adalah bahwa kita akan memperlakukan generator stabilizer sebagai observable, dan dengan mensyaratkan bahwa
semuanya commute, kita memastikan bahwa urutan di mana kita melakukan pengukuran ini tidak
berpengaruh. Kedua, generator stabilizer harus membentuk himpunan pembangkit minimal, yang berarti jika kita menghapus salah satu
satu di antaranya, kita akan mendapat stabilizer yang lebih kecil. Dan satu cara untuk mengungkapkan ini secara matematis ditunjukkan di sini di
layar. Secara ketat, kondisi ini tidak benar-benar penting bagi cara kerja kode stabilizer secara operasional
dan kadang-kadang memang masuk akal untuk memikirkan himpunan pembangkit non-minimal seperti yang akan kita lihat di pelajaran berikutnya, tapi
demi menganalisis kode stabilizer dan menjelaskan sifat-sifatnya, kita akan mengasumsikan bahwa kondisi ini ada
tempatnya. Pada dasarnya kondisi ini menjamin bahwa setiap observable yang kita ukur untuk mendapatkan syndrome adalah menambah
informasi tentang kemungkinan error, bukan berlebihan dan memberikan hasil yang bisa dengan mudah disimpulkan dari generator stabilizer lain sebagai
observable. Dan akhirnya, harus ada setidaknya satu vektor non-nol yang ditetapkan oleh semua
generator stabilizer, dan itu ternyata ekuivalen dengan menuntut bahwa -1 dikali identitas pada N qubit adalah
tidak terkandung dalam stabilizer. Itu tidak jelas tapi intinya adalah bahwa memang mungkin untuk memilih himpunan pembangkit minimal
dari operasi Pauli N qubit yang semuanya commute satu sama lain dan namun tidak ada vektor yang secara simultan merupakan vektor eigen plus satu
dari semuanya, dan kita tidak ingin memikirkan kemungkinan ini karena kode di mana tidak ada encoding yang valid bukanlah
hal yang menarik. Jadi itulah persyaratan pada generator stabilizer untuk kode stabilizer, dan jika kita memiliki himpunan generator yang
memenuhi kondisi-kondisi ini maka kita punya kode stabilizer yang valid dan kita bisa mempertimbangkan sifat-sifatnya. Ada banyak
kode stabilizer yang berbeda dengan berbagai sifat yang membuatnya menarik atau tidak, tapi semuanya memenuhi sifat dasar tertentu
yang mengingatkan kita pada yang sudah kita amati untuk repetition code tiga bit.
Kita akan melihat beberapa contoh sebentar lagi tapi sebelum itu izinkan saya menyebutkan bahwa ketika kita menyebut code space dari kode stabilizer, yang kita maksud adalah subruang
dari ruang keadaan N qubit yang mencakup setiap vektor yang secara simultan merupakan vektor eigen plus satu dari setiap satu
dari generator stabilizer. Ini adalah subruang dari ruang keadaan N qubit tempat encoding yang valid hidup, dan kita akan punya lebih banyak hal untuk
dikatakan tentang subruang ini seiring pelajaran berlanjut. Sekarang mari lihat beberapa contoh kode stabilizer.
Ini adalah contoh yang sudah kita diskusikan yaitu repetition code 3-bit biasa, dan kita juga bisa mengungkapkan
versi modifikasi dari kode itu dari pelajaran sebelumnya yang bisa mendeteksi phase flip alih-alih bit flip sebagai kode stabilizer seperti yang ditunjukkan
di sini. Kali ini generator stabilizer mengukur observable XX bukan observable ZZ, jadi ini pada dasarnya
adalah pemeriksaan paritas dalam basis plus minus bukan basis standar. Dalam kedua kasus, kita bisa
langsung melihat bahwa kita punya kode stabilizer yang valid karena generator stabilizer commute. Ini adalah himpunan pembangkit
minimal dan code space-nya tidak trivial seperti yang sudah kita tahu. Tapi kita juga bisa melihat dengan cukup jelas bahwa kita
tidak bisa menghasilkan negatif -1 dikali identitas. Dan ini adalah 9 qubit Shore code yang juga merupakan kode stabilizer
yang diungkapkan oleh generator stabilizer. Dalam kasus ini, kita pada dasarnya punya tiga salinan dari repetition code tiga bit,
satu untuk masing-masing dari tiga blok tiga qubit, beserta dua generator stabilizer terakhir yang
mengambil bentuk yang mengingatkan pada circuit yang kita lihat di pelajaran sebelumnya untuk mendeteksi phase flip untuk kode ini.
Cara lain untuk memikirkan dua generator stabilizer terakhir ini adalah bahwa mereka mengambil bentuk yang persis sama seperti yang kita
miliki untuk repetition code tiga bit untuk phase flip kecuali bahwa kita mengganti XXX untuk X. Dan alasannya adalah
bahwa XXX bersesuaian dengan operasi X pada qubit Logical yang di-encode menggunakan repetition code 3-bit tapi
itu adalah catatan tambahan dan bukan sesuatu yang perlu dikhawatirkan sekarang. Jika belum jelas, selanjutnya kita akan melihat beberapa
contoh lagi tapi sebelum itu izinkan saya menyebutkan bahwa orang sering menghilangkan simbol perkalian tensor saat mendeskripsikan kode stabilizer karena cenderung
membuatnya lebih mudah dibaca. Jadi begini tampilan kode-kode ini tanpa simbol perkalian tensor
tapi tentu saja ini adalah perkalian tensor bukan perkalian matriks biasa. Misalnya, kita hanya menghilangkan simbol perkalian tensor agar tidak terlalu
berantakan dan polanya lebih jelas. Berikut contoh lain yang disebut
7 qubit Steane code dan memiliki beberapa fitur yang cukup luar biasa. Kita akan kembali ke yang ini
dari waktu ke waktu sepanjang pelajaran-pelajaran yang tersisa dari unit ini, tapi untuk sekarang kita bisa cukup memverifikasi bahwa ini adalah kode stabilizer yang valid.
Khususnya, tiga generator stabilizer pertama jelas commute satu sama lain karena Z commute dengan
WEBVTT
dirinya sendiri dan identitas commute dengan segalanya, dan situasinya serupa untuk tiga yang terakhir. Jadi yang perlu
diperiksa adalah jika kita mengambil salah satu generator stabilizer Z dan salah satu generator stabilizer X maka keduanya commute,
dan cukup mudah untuk memeriksa sembilan kemungkinan pasangan untuk memastikan bahwa dalam semua kasus ini kita akan selalu
mendapati X dan Z yang berada di posisi yang sama sejumlah genap kali sehingga kedua generator akan commute, seperti
XX dan ZZ yang commute. Ini adalah himpunan pembangkit minimal dan memiliki code space yang tidak trivial tapi
saya tidak akan mencoba membuktikannya dalam video ini dan sebaliknya saya akan biarkan itu untukmu pikirkan jika kamu mau. 7 qubit Steane code serupa
dengan 9 qubit Shore code dalam arti bahwa ia meng-encode satu qubit dan memungkinkan koreksi error sembarang pada satu qubit tapi ia hanya
membutuhkan tujuh qubit, bukan sembilan. Itu bukan jumlah qubit terkecil yang diperlukan untuk kode koreksi error agar bisa
meng-encode sebuah qubit dan mengoreksi error sembarang pada satu qubit. Berikut adalah kode stabilizer yang
biasanya disebut five qubit code yang juga meng-encode satu qubit dan bisa mengoreksi error qubit tunggal yang sembarang
dan lima adalah jumlah qubit terkecil yang memungkinkan hal ini. Berikut contoh lain dari kode stabilizer
meskipun sebenarnya bukan kode dalam arti tertentu karena code space-nya adalah
satu dimensi. Khususnya, code space untuk kode ini adalah ruang yang dibentang oleh sebuah ebit atau dengan kata lain keadaan Bell phi plus
sehingga kamu sebenarnya tidak bisa meng-encode qubit apapun menggunakan kode ini tapi ini tetap merupakan kode stabilizer yang valid di mana code
space-nya kebetulan satu dimensi, dan mungkin juga melakukan hal serupa untuk keadaan
GHZ. Jadi itulah beberapa contoh kode stabilizer dan kita akan melihat lebih banyak lagi contoh yang tak terhingga dalam
pelajaran berikutnya. Misalkan kita diberikan kode stabilizer. Pertanyaan alami yang perlu ditanyakan tentangnya
mungkin pertanyaan pertama yang terlintas dalam pikiran adalah berapa banyak qubit yang di-encode-nya. Pertanyaan itu punya jawaban yang sangat sederhana
dan untuk menjelaskannya mari kita tepat tentang kode stabilizer yang sedang dipertimbangkan. Kita punya R generator stabilizer N qubit
P1 sampai PR yang memenuhi tiga persyaratan yang saya sebutkan sebelumnya yaitu bahwa
generator stabilizer semuanya commute satu sama lain, ini adalah himpunan pembangkit minimal sehingga kita tidak akan mendapatkan
stabilizer yang sama jika kita menghapus salah satu generator, dan ada setidaknya satu vektor non-nol dalam code
space. Seperti yang ditunjukkan teorema di layar, maka harus ada code space dari kode stabilizer yang memiliki
dimensi 2 pangkat N minus R, atau cara lain untuk mengatakannya adalah bahwa kita bisa meng-encode N
minus R qubit menggunakan kode ini. Jadi secara intuitif, kita punya N qubit dalam encoding kita dan setiap
generator stabilizer secara efektif mengambil satu qubit dalam hal berapa banyak qubit yang bisa kita encode.
Teorema ini tidak terlalu sulit untuk dibuktikan dan saya akan menunjukkan buktinya sebentar lagi, tapi pertama kita akan melihat
beberapa contoh saja. Mulai dengan repetition code 3-bit biasa, kita punya tiga qubit dalam
encoding kita sehingga N sama dengan tiga dan ada R sama dengan 2 generator stabilizer sehingga kita bisa meng-encode satu
qubit menggunakan kode ini. Perhatikan bahwa ini bukan tentang mana atau berapa banyak error yang bisa dideteksi atau
dikoreksi, itu adalah masalah yang berbeda. Ini hanyalah pernyataan tentang dimensi dari code
space. Untuk contoh lain, pertimbangkan five qubit code. Di sini kita punya lima qubit dan empat
generator stabilizer sehingga sekali lagi code space memiliki dimensi dua yang berarti kita bisa meng-encode satu qubit menggunakan
kode ini. Dan satu contoh lagi untuk sekarang: untuk kode stabilizer ebit, kita punya dua qubit dan dua generator stabilizer sehingga
code space adalah satu dimensi dan seperti yang saya sebutkan sebelumnya, itu adalah ruang yang dibentang oleh keadaan Bell phi plus.
Kita akan melihat lebih banyak contoh seiring kita melanjutkan termasuk kode di mana kita bisa meng-encode lebih dari satu qubit, tapi untuk sekarang mari
lihat bagaimana kita bisa membuktikan teorema tersebut. Hal pertama yang perlu kita amati adalah bahwa karena generator
stabilizer commute dan membentuk himpunan pembangkit minimal dan karena setiap operasi Pauli adalah inversnya sendiri, setiap
elemen dalam stabilizer bisa diungkapkan dengan cara yang unik sebagai perkalian di mana kita menaikkan setiap generator stabilizer
PK ke pangkat AK di mana setiap AK adalah Z atau satu lalu kita mengalikan hasilnya
bersama. Cara lain untuk mengatakan ini adalah bahwa kita mendapatkan setiap elemen dari stabilizer dengan mengalikan bersama beberapa subset dari
generator stabilizer dan kita tidak pernah mendapatkan elemen stabilizer yang sama dari subset yang berbeda. Dan satu hal yang
ini implikasikan adalah bahwa satu-satunya cara untuk mengungkapkan operasi identitas N qubit dengan cara ini adalah mengambil semua pangkat menjadi
nol. Selanjutnya, mari definisikan pi K sebagai proyeksi ke ruang eigen plus satu dari PK untuk setiap K dari 1 sampai R. Dan ada
formula sederhana untuk proyeksi ini. Kita bisa cukup merata-ratakan PK dengan identitas pada N qubit yang secara efektif membiarkan nilai
eigen plus satu sendiri dan menggeser semua nilai eigen minus satu ke nilai
nol. Sekarang code space didefinisikan sebagai himpunan semua vektor yang secara simultan merupakan vektor eigen plus satu dari semua
generator stabilizer. Mengingat generator stabilizer commute, proyeksinya juga harus commute dan itu
mengimplikasikan bahwa hasil kali dari proyeksi-proyeksi ini juga merupakan proyeksi. Dan khususnya, itu adalah proyeksi ke
persimpangan dari subruang-subruang yang diproyeksikan masing-masing proyeksi, atau dengan kata lain itu adalah proyeksi ke
code space. Kita bisa mengembangkan hasil kali ini dan apa yang kita dapatkan adalah rata-rata atas setiap
elemen dari stabilizer. Dan akhirnya karena dimensi dari subruang manapun sama dengan
jejak proyeksi ke subruang itu, kita menemukan bahwa dimensi dari code space adalah rata-rata dari jejak-jejak atas elemen-elemen dari
stabilizer. Tapi dengan pengecualian operasi identitas N qubit, semua elemen dari stabilizer harus memiliki
jejak sama dengan nol karena tiga matriks Pauli non-identitas semuanya punya jejak sama dengan nol. Jejak dari operasi identitas N qubit
adalah 2 pangkat N sehingga kita menemukan bahwa dimensi dari code space adalah 2 pangkat N minus R yang membuktikan
teorema. Selanjutnya saya akan sedikit membahas tentang bagaimana qubit bisa di-encode menggunakan kode stabilizer, tapi untuk melakukan itu kita pertama
perlu memperkenalkan operasi Clifford. Operasi Clifford adalah operasi unitary pada qubit dalam jumlah berapa pun
yang bisa diimplementasikan oleh circuit Quantum dengan himpunan gate yang terbatas yaitu Hadamard Gate, S Gate,
dan gate controlled-NOT. Perhatikan bahwa T gate tidak termasuk, begitu juga Toffoli gate atau Fredkin
gate. Dan bukan hanya gate-gate itu tidak termasuk dalam daftar ini tapi sebenarnya tidak mungkin untuk mengimplementasikan gate-gate tersebut
WEBVTT
menggunakan yang tercantum di sini, jadi mereka bukan operasi Clifford. Operasi Pauli di sisi lain
adalah operasi Clifford dan khususnya bisa diimplementasikan menggunakan urutan Hadamard dan S
gate. Jadi itulah cara sederhana untuk mendefinisikan operasi Clifford, tapi ini tidak benar-benar menjelaskan mengapa mereka didefinisikan seperti
ini atau apa yang istimewa tentang koleksi gate tertentu ini. Berikut adalah alasan sebenarnya mengapa operasi Clifford didefinisikan seperti
ini. Hingga fase global, operasi Clifford N qubit adalah tepat operasi unitary
yang selalu mengubah operasi Pauli menjadi operasi Pauli melalui konjugasi. Lebih tepatnya, operasi unitary N qubit
U adalah operasi Clifford hingga faktor fase global jika dan hanya jika untuk setiap operasi Pauli N qubit,
konjugasi operasi Pauli tersebut dengan U memberi kita plus atau minus satu dikali beberapa operasi Pauli N
qubit yang mungkin berbeda. Kamu bisa dengan mudah memeriksa bahwa properti ini benar untuk Hadamard gate, S
gate, dan gate CNOT, sehingga ini tentu berlaku untuk circuit yang dibangun dari gate-gate ini. Yang lebih sulit untuk dibuktikan adalah bahwa itu
berlaku dalam arah lain, yaitu bahwa jika kita diberikan operasi unitary N qubit tertentu U yang memenuhi properti ini
maka pasti bisa diimplementasikan hingga fase global menggunakan hanya Hadamard, S, dan CNOT
gate. Saya tidak akan membuktikan implikasi itu tapi memang benar dan kamu bisa mencarinya jika kamu
tertarik. Operasi Clifford bukanlah operasi universal untuk komputasi Quantum, artinya kita tidak bisa menjalankan komputasi Quantum yang sembarang
menggunakan hanya Hadamard, S, dan CNOT gate. Sebenarnya untuk nilai N tertentu, hanya ada finitely banyak
operasi Clifford N qubit sehingga ini adalah himpunan operasi yang diskrit. Jadi berbeda dengan
himpunan gate Quantum universal, kita tidak bisa mengaproksimasi operasi unitary yang sembarang hingga tingkat akurasi yang diinginkan. Dan
sebenarnya melakukan operasi Clifford pada keadaan basis standar yang diikuti oleh pengukuran basis standar tidak bisa memungkinkan
kita untuk melakukan komputasi yang berada di luar jangkauan algoritma klasik karena kita bisa mensimulasikan komputasi dalam bentuk ini secara efisien
secara klasik. Fakta ini dikenal sebagai teorema Gottesman-Knill dan bukti standar dari teorema itu dalam arti tertentu
didasarkan pada formalisme stabilizer. Khususnya, cara kerjanya adalah kita bisa melacak cara operasi Clifford mengubah operasi Pauli
melalui konjugasi, yang bisa dilakukan secara efisien, lalu menyimpulkan dari itu apa yang komputasi lakukan pada
qubit. Jadi apa hubungannya ini dengan kode stabilizer? Nah, kode stabilizer memberikan kita
code space dengan dimensi tertentu dan kita memiliki kebebasan untuk menggunakan code space tersebut sesuka kita, sehingga tidak ada yang memaksa kita untuk meng-encode
qubit ke dalam ruang tersebut dengan cara tertentu tapi selalu mungkin untuk melakukan encoding menggunakan operasi Clifford
sebagai encoder. Itu bagus karena operasi Clifford relatif sederhana dibandingkan dengan operasi unitary yang sembarang.
Ada cara untuk mengoptimalkan implementasinya yang bekerja dengan cara yang serupa dengan bukti teorema Gottesman-
Knill, dan sebagai hasilnya circuit untuk mengimplementasikannya tidak perlu terlalu
besar. Khususnya, kita selalu bisa melakukan encoding menggunakan operasi Clifford yang membutuhkan sedikit kurang dari jumlah gate kuadratik
karena itu sebenarnya berlaku untuk setiap operasi Clifford. Jadi intinya adalah bahwa untuk kode stabilizer tertentu, selalu
mungkin untuk meng-encode qubit secara efisien menggunakan kode tersebut, dan alat matematis yang berguna untuk memahami operasi Clifford bisa membantu proses
ini. Misalnya, berikut encoder untuk 7 qubit Steane code. Ini adalah operasi Clifford dan ternyata
yang ini bahkan tidak memerlukan S gate. Untuk kode stabilizer secara umum, deteksi error bekerja dengan cara berikut:
seperti sebelumnya, kita akan mengasumsikan bahwa kita punya generator stabilizer N qubit P1 sampai PR dan kita akan membiarkan E menjadi operasi Pauli N qubit
yang merepresentasikan error hipotetis pada sebuah encoding. Kita hanya mempertimbangkan operasi Pauli
sebagai error omong-omong, karena diskretisasi error bekerja dengan cara yang sama untuk kode stabilizer yang sembarang seperti yang dilakukan untuk 9 qubit Shore
code. Cara kita memeriksa error adalah dengan mengukur masing-masing generator stabilizer sebagai
observable. Ada R generator stabilizer sehingga ini berarti R hasil di mana masing-masing adalah plus satu atau minus satu,
atau nilai biner jika kamu lebih suka mengasosiasikan nol dengan plus satu dan satu dengan minus satu. Dan R hasil ini
bersama-sama membentuk syndrome seperti yang kita miliki untuk repetition code tiga bit ketika R sama dengan
dua. Secara umum ada tiga kemungkinan kasus untuk error E dalam hal deteksinya dan mereka adalah sebagai berikut. Pertama,
bisa jadi E ada dalam stabilizer yang berarti mungkin untuk menghasilkan E dari generator stabilizer, atau
sedikit lebih umum, bisa jadi E ekuivalen dengan elemen stabilizer hingga fase
global. Dalam kasus ini, E sebenarnya bukan error sama sekali karena tidak berpengaruh dalam code space selain mungkin
menyuntikkan fase global yang tidak memiliki efek apapun. Jadi kita tidak perlu khawatir sama sekali tentang error seperti ini. Apapun
aksi non-trivial yang mungkin dimilikinya terjadi di luar code space sehingga itu tidak menjadi perhatian
kita. Jauh lebih menjadi perhatian adalah kemungkinan bahwa E tidak ada dalam stabilizer bahkan hingga fase global tapi
meskipun demikian E commute dengan setiap satu dari generator stabilizer kita. Ingat bahwa yang menyebabkan minus satu muncul di suatu tempat dalam syndrome adalah
anti-komutasi dari error dengan generator stabilizer
tapi itu tidak terjadi dalam kasus ini, jadi ini adalah error yang sebenarnya mengubah vektor dalam code space dalam beberapa cara
yang non-trivial. Dan kita tahu ini karena kalau tidak maka itu akan proporsional dengan elemen stabilizer, tapi itu
tidak terdeteksi oleh kode. Jadi ini adalah kasus buruk: kita punya error yang berpotensi mengubah
informasi Quantum yang kita encode tapi kode tidak menyadari fakta ini. Misalnya, untuk repetition code tiga bit,
XXX termasuk dalam kategori ini. Dan kemungkinan terakhir adalah bahwa E anti-commute dengan setidaknya satu dari generator stabilizer
dan ini berarti bahwa kode mendeteksi error ini karena
kita akan mendapatkan syndrome dengan setidaknya satu minus satu di suatu tempat yang menunjukkan bahwa ada sesuatu yang salah dan kita perlu mencoba untuk mengoreksi error ini
dengan cara tertentu. Jadi itulah kemungkinan-kemungkinannya. Sebagai poin terminologi,
ketika kita menyebut jarak dari kode stabilizer, yang kita maksud adalah bobot minimum dari operasi Pauli yang termasuk
dalam kategori kedua, yang berarti mengubah code space dengan cara yang non-trivial tapi kode tidak
mendeteksi ini. Dan ketika kita mengatakan bahwa kode stabilizer adalah kode stabilizer [[N, M, D]] menggunakan
tanda kurung siku ganda seperti yang ditunjukkan di layar, yang dimaksud adalah encoding-nya panjangnya N qubit,
WEBVTT
kode mampu meng-encode M qubit sehingga code space berdimensi 2 pangkat M dan jaraknya adalah D. Jadi sebuah error harus
memiliki bobot D atau lebih untuk mengubah keadaan Logical dari qubit yang kita encode tanpa terdeteksi sebagai
error. Kita sekarang akan melihat 7 qubit Steane code sebagai contoh dan kita akan menentukan apa jaraknya.
Berikut adalah generator stabilizer untuk kode ini dan ingat bahwa jarak adalah bobot minimum dari operasi Pauli N qubit
yang commute dengan semua generator stabilizer tapi sendirinya tidak ada dalam stabilizer maupun
proporsional dengan elemen dari stabilizer. Yang akan kita tentukan adalah bahwa kode ini memiliki jarak
tiga. Cara kita menentukannya adalah dengan pertama mempertimbangkan operasi Pauli manapun yang berbobot paling banyak dua dan kita akan
menyimpulkan bahwa satu-satunya cara ia bisa commute dengan semua enam generator stabilizer adalah jika itu adalah identitas yang selalu merupakan elemen dari
stabilizer. Jadi anggap saja matriks Pauli yang mungkin non-identitas yang membentuk operasi ini yang akan kita
sebut P dan Q muncul di dua posisi paling kiri. Ini hanyalah satu kasus dan kita memang harus
mempertimbangkan semua lokasi lain yang mungkin untuk matriks Pauli yang mungkin non-identitas ini tapi argumennya pada dasarnya sama untuk semua
lokasi yang mungkin. Nah berdasarkan asumsi, operasi ini commute dengan semua enam
generator stabilizer, jadi khususnya ia commute dengan yang ini dan ia juga commute dengan yang
ini. Q berada di posisi matriks identitas dalam kedua generator ini itulah mengapa kita memilih keduanya, dan kita punya matriks
identitas di lima posisi paling kanan dari error ini, sehingga kita menyimpulkan bahwa P harus commute dengan X
dan Z karena kalau tidak error ini akan anti-commute dengan salah satu dari dua generator ini. Tapi satu-satunya matriks Pauli yang
commute dengan X dan Z adalah identitas, jadi P harus identitas dan sekarang setelah kita mengetahui itu, kita
bisa memilih dua generator stabilizer lagi yang punya X dan Z di posisi kedua dari kiri dan kita bisa
menarik kesimpulan serupa tentang Q. Jadi tidak ada cara bagi error berbobot paling banyak 2 untuk lolos tanpa terdeteksi oleh kode ini
kecuali itu hanyalah operasi identitas yang ada dalam stabilizer sehingga ini sebenarnya bukan
error. Di sisi lain, ada operasi Pauli berbobot tiga yang commute dengan semua enam dari generator stabilizer ini
tapi tidak proporsional dengan elemen stabilizer, dan berikut dua contoh. Jadi kita menyimpulkan bahwa
kode ini memiliki jarak tiga. Hal terakhir yang akan kita diskusikan dalam pelajaran ini adalah mengoreksi error untuk
kode stabilizer. Seperti biasa kita akan mengasumsikan kode kita ditentukan oleh generator stabilizer N qubit
P1 sampai PR dan mari mulai dengan memikirkan sedikit tentang semua kemungkinan error yang bisa
terjadi. Ada 2 pangkat R kemungkinan syndrome dan seperti yang saya sebutkan tadi dalam pelajaran ini, syndrome-syndrome tersebut mempartisi semua
kemungkinan operasi Pauli N qubit menjadi koleksi-koleksi berukuran sama. Jadi itu berarti 4 pangkat N dibagi 2 pangkat R operasi Pauli
dalam setiap himpunan. Jadi ketika kita melihat syndrome tertentu, bisa jadi salah satu dari 4 pangkat N dibagi 2
pangkat R error ini yang bertanggung jawab. Kita sedikit menghitung berlebihan di sini meskipun karena beberapa dari
error ini memiliki efek yang persis sama pada code space. Khususnya, jika kita punya error E dan kita mengalikan E dengan elemen stabilizer S manapun,
maka kita akan mendapatkan error lain yang memiliki efek yang persis sama dalam code space seperti E, sehingga
ini adalah error yang ekuivalen. Stabilizer memiliki 2 pangkat R elemen dan jika kita memperhitungkan ini maka kita menemukan
bahwa untuk setiap syndrome ada 4 pangkat N minus R kelas ekuivalensi dari error yang bisa menyebabkan syndrome tersebut.
Dan yang itu berarti adalah bahwa kecuali R sama dengan N di mana kita punya code space satu dimensi dan
karenanya tidak bisa meng-encode qubit sama sekali, tidak akan mungkin untuk mengoreksi setiap error yang bisa kita deteksi. Sebaliknya,
yang harus kita lakukan adalah memilih hanya satu operasi koreksi untuk setiap syndrome dengan harapan hanya mengoreksi satu kelas error yang ekuivalen.
Jadi bagaimana kita harus memilih koreksi apa yang harus dilakukan untuk setiap syndrome? Strategi alami adalah memilih
operasi Pauli berbobot terendah yang menyebabkan syndrome yang kita ukur, dengan ide bahwa operasi Pauli berbobot lebih rendah
merepresentasikan penjelasan yang lebih mungkin untuk syndrome tersebut. Ini mungkin sebenarnya bukan
kasus untuk beberapa model noise, dan strategi alami lainnya adalah entah bagaimana menghitung error yang paling mungkin yang menyebabkan
syndrome yang diberikan. Tapi untuk sekarang kita hanya akan mempertimbangkan strategi di mana kita mencoba mengoreksi error dengan memilih operasi Pauli berbobot terendah yang menyebabkan
syndrome. Untuk kode stabilizer berjarak D, strategi ini akan selalu memungkinkan kita untuk mengoreksi error dengan bobot secara ketat
kurang dari setengah D, atau dengan kata lain bobot paling banyak D minus 1 dibagi 2. Dan saya akan menjelaskan secara singkat mengapa ini
terjadi. Ini akan menunjukkan misalnya bahwa 7 qubit Steane code bisa mengoreksi error Pauli berbobot satu manapun dan melalui
diskretisasi error ini berarti bahwa seperti 9 qubit Shore code, Steane code bisa mengoreksi error yang sembarang
pada satu qubit. Jadi begini cara ini bekerja. Anggap lingkaran ini merepresentasikan semua kemungkinan operasi Pauli
yang menghasilkan syndrome all-plus-1 yang merupakan syndrome yang menunjukkan bahwa tidak ada error yang terjadi
dan semuanya baik-baik saja. Di antara operasi-operasi ini kita punya elemen-elemen stabilizer atau benar-benar
operasi yang proporsional dengan elemen stabilizer, dan kita juga punya error non-trivial yang mengubah code space dengan cara tertentu tapi tidak
terdeteksi oleh kode. Dan kita tahu berdasarkan definisi jarak bahwa setiap operasi Pauli dalam kategori ini harus berbobot setidaknya
D karena D didefinisikan sebagai bobot minimum dari operasi-operasi ini. Kita juga punya operasi Pauli
yang menyebabkan syndrome lain muncul dan kita bisa mempertimbangkan setiap syndrome secara bergiliran jika kita mau, tapi di sini kita hanya membayangkan
bahwa satu syndrome S telah muncul. Sekarang bayangkan bahwa E adalah error dalam
kategori ini yang berbobot secara ketat kurang dari setengah jarak D. Nah kita tidak tahu bahwa ini
adalah operasi Pauli berbobot minimum dalam lingkaran ini, jadi mari ambil C sebagai operasi berbobot minimum dalam himpunan ini, atau salah satunya jika ada seri.
Jadi bisa jadi C sama dengan E atau mungkin tidak, tapi karena C memiliki
bobot minimum, kita tahu bahwa tidak mungkin memiliki bobot yang lebih besar dari bobot E karena C juga ada dalam himpunan
dan memiliki bobot minimal. Jadi operasi koreksi C harus berbobot secara ketat kurang dari setengah
D. Jadi apa yang terjadi jika kita menerapkan koreksi C ini ke apapun keadaan kita setelah error E
terjadi? Jawabannya adalah bahwa keadaan yang kita peroleh adalah C dikali E yang dikalikan ke encoding asli karena kita pertama
kali mengalikan dengan E yaitu error lalu kita mengalikan dengan C untuk mencoba mengoreksinya. Dan hasil kali ini harus ada dalam
WEBVTT
stabilizer atau proporsional dengan elemen stabilizer, dan ini alasannya. Pertama karena E dan C memberikan kita
syndrome yang sama, C dikali E harus memberikan kita syndrome all-plus-one. Itu karena untuk generator stabilizer tertentu,
entah C dan E keduanya commute dengan generator tersebut atau keduanya anti-commute. Harus sama untuk
keduanya karena syndrome-nya sama. Dan jika kamu memikirkan itu sebentar, itu mengimplikasikan bahwa C dikali E harus
commute dengan semua generator stabilizer. Dan akhirnya C dikali E harus
ada dalam stabilizer karena bobotnya tidak bisa lebih besar dari jumlah bobot C dan E, sehingga bobotnya
secara ketat kurang dari D. Dan ini berarti bahwa kita berhasil mengoreksi E karena menerapkan E diikuti oleh C tidak melakukan apa-apa pada
code space. Jadi itu bagus tapi ada satu masalah saja yaitu bahwa untuk kode stabilizer
secara umum, ini adalah masalah yang sulit secara komputasional untuk menghitung operasi berbobot terendah yang menyebabkan syndrome tertentu.
Dan memang itu benar bahkan untuk kode klasik yang dalam konteks ini bisa kita pikirkan sebagai kode stabilizer
di mana kita hanya punya matriks identitas dan matriks Pauli Z yang muncul sebagai faktor tensor dalam generator
stabilizer. Jadi berbeda dengan langkah encoding, operasi Clifford kali ini tidak datang untuk menyelamatkan kita, dan satu-satunya solusi yang wajar
adalah memilih kode-kode tertentu yang koreksi baiknya bisa dihitung secara efisien, dan tidak ada resep untuk
ini. Singkatnya, merancang kode stabilizer seperti ini adalah bagian dari seni
desain kode Quantum. Dan itu adalah tempat yang baik untuk berhenti untuk pelajaran ini. Saya harap kamu akan bergabung dengan saya
di pelajaran berikutnya di mana kita akan melihat beberapa konstruksi kode Quantum tertentu termasuk kode-kode yang menggambarkan seni desain kode Quantum
dengan cara yang cukup spektakuler. Sampai jumpa.